[Music]
this is a final thought but it's because
it's book lovers day is we're going to
turn it into a sort of stuff I like I'll
tell you about the books that I've been
reading over the last couple years and I
highly recommend them the first one is
poetic diction by Owen Barfield he was
an inkling friend of CS Lewis and all of
those other guys he it's a great book
it's a theory of knowledge and a theory
of language this was recommended to me
by Andrew Clavin who actually reads
books I read like two books a decade and
he's read all of the books so he's been
evangelical about recommending this book
to people it's really good I think
especially conservatives and people who
prefer traditional culture and have an
interest in history and philosophy would
really like it so run out there and get
poetic diction the next book I have to
recommend is of course speaking of
Andrew Clavin the great good thing a
secular Jew comes to faith in Christ I
read this book right when it came out I
got an advance copy of it it's an
amazing story of Andrew clavin's
conversion from a secular intellectual
Jew in New York to a Christian and and
he talks about his politics as well and
the literature that brought him along
that journey it's really a profound book
I myself am a revert to Christianity I
it was very edifying to read that and
then when you go to the beach this book
we got to give a little love to ben
shapiro you all know that ben can type
about 120 words per minute he also as
you know speaks about 190 words per
minute and this book flies by it is such
a page-turner true allegiance it is a
fever dream of armageddon from the
conservative standpoint it's really
entertaining it's terrific so when
you're going to the beach i recommend
reading that i promise you you won't be
able to read it as fast as been typed it
and speaking of typing books really fast
the final recommendation I have to make
a little self-serving the reasons to
vote for Democrats a comprehensive guide
the most exhaustive Democratic Party
apologize ow I it's really good I can
even the president endorsed it he said
it's a great book for your reading
enjoyment even Ben Shapiro endorsed it
he called it thorough I really think as
you gear up for the school year as you
gear up for the fall you
want to edify yourself you want to learn
more about our political systems and
American history and American political
philosophy go out there you also have to
get reasons to vote for Democrats happy
book lovers day I'm glad that we had
this lovely trans final thought segment
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
no Leo come back tomorrow we'll do it
again
[Music]